hi my name is Vincent Staples and this
is me reviewing every [ __ ] thing
American Apparel one piece for the
people that's living at MetLife I'm
about a quality bra from Long Beach
we got a gay parade it's 2016 why are
gonna shouldn't look like that anymore
like we need a advance our technology
this is pathetic let's go throw the tire
I don't want I don't like that the
facial structure still that of a white
man with the brown skin have you seen
the trailer for the movie about the
Great Wall of China starring Matt Damon
we got somewhere to go we need to
respect the handi-capable I've never
seen nobody in a wheelchair just taking
a [ __ ] time they always got somewhere
to go perspective that's like a where're
you from bro scout that's the face you
make when you really need to know like
where he's from that's a real question
at some times ponytail is a bad
placement after brexit the second one is
quiet lady cop is cool lady construction
workers cool I'm a fan of that but
that's the girl from inside out kind of
makes me sad she's working out that's
okay she's has anxiety issues because
she feels like she's not being
appreciated by you know the rest of the
living creatures on this earth and she's
properly in New York City walking down
the street no one asked her how her day
is she really needs a hand or someone
you don't show interest in her
well-being but they're not doing that so
she's kind of self reflecting and
feeling as if she's alone in the world I
don't really have nothing to say about
nothing y'all just asked me to do this
[ __ ]